the five most amazing moves of Aleppo
the Russian samurai now nepo is a
fantastic player and very tactically
minded and in this video which you need
to like and subscribe now we're going to
have a look at five of his most magical
moments on the chessboard and hopefully
you'll learn something and enjoy these
five sparkling moves as well this first
example is a demonstration in albeit a
strange way of the Greek gift the Greek
gift is when you do a move such as
Bishop takes h7 check and that is the
move here but it's actually the next
move which is very tricky
do you remember you can pause if you
need to and this was all opening
preparation but what is the idea after
King takes h7 has white just played a
crazy sacrifice that doesn't work or the
course not he has a brilliant follow up
one of my favorite moves h4 here comes
the little slider my friend my jolly
good friend Harry Harry the very brave H
pawn and a point of this move is white
sets up the knight coming into this
square on g5 and if any moment is to
capture there that rook on h1 is
unleashed and this leads to a very good
position for white not quite winning but
white is a pawn up what can black do
well if black moves the bishop on g5
let's say to h6 for example then Knight
to g5 check demonstrates this idea we're
getting ready to take the bishop on g4
and if Bishop takes g5 the whole point
is shown HTH g5 is check very unique
tactic after the king moves we can
simply take the bishop with a monstrous
attack on the H file and an extra pawn
that's the kind of compensation I like I
like being a pawn up with the
compensation
what else can black do after h4 well you
can have a look at the smooze yourself
but black is in a dire situation with
this Knight g5 the game continued Bishop
to D to check rather desperate
and after some more logical moves here a
very nice little move Intermezzo means
of move in the middle of a combination
Queen 2d free check and queen take set
free
Napo was simply a pawn up with a very
strong position and he went on to win
good preparation it can count massively
especially as we're looking at these
players you could face Magnus they're
gonna need a good team behind them nepo
clearly has just that on to example
number two some neppo fire on the board
now you can see here that the black king
is lacking a lot of adequate protection
all the black's pieces are over on the
Queen side what are they doing you need
to protect your king your King is a very
important piece I hear in chess so how
can white and how did neppo break
through with a series of beautiful blows
and this is maybe not just one move but
it's a couple of moves and the second
move is simply stunning can you see it
and well done if you do is not easy well
we need to break down the porn
protection so the first move is Knights
on G takes f7 this pretty much forces
rook takes f7 and now comes the real
stunner we can't really just take that
rook and hopefully better because the
two Knights were better than the rook
and pawn but what do we do and this must
have been a lovely move just to slide
along the board like a surfer riding a
wave Queen to h6 check what a stunning
move this is absolutely amazing you're
leaving the Queen to be captured by the
King but if it is captured now this
Knight becomes an absolute superstar
Knight takes f7 one rook down and now we
have what we call a major fork so fork
so fork such a big fork I can just
picture it now the King has to move and
we take the Queen with a winning game
the game actually continued with King to
g8 and now Knight takes f7 a lot
stronger because our Queen has entered
into a much stronger position and after
King takes
one more blow what would you play here
remember you can pause rook takes f7 and
this creates some problems on the
seventh Frank or it allows us to take
the bishop after Queen takes the simple
move now as the knight is defending the
Queen Bishop takes d5 removing a
defender if that Bishop is taken we win
the Queen and clearly now White has a
winning position beautiful tactics there
one after another from
nepo who really is a beautiful and
brilliant tactician as is shown here I'm
now going to show you a case of Nepos
Funkadelic night and just watch this
little guy on be free bougie the night
away the Knights are one of my favorite
pieces and neppo demonstrates just how
tricky they can be here it's being
attacked at the moment and maybe a less
astute player would now simply move the
knight to d4 but there's a much more
aggressive way to play with this knight
Knight to c5 and this takes example of
the Queen being on the GFR and the
pressure on the knight on f6 this Knight
is seemingly jumping into a square it
can be captured but if it is captured
Bishop takes f6 leads to an incredibly
strong attack so the Funkadelic Knight
it continues to dance its little boogie
after rook to a5 and where does it go
next and I love the way this Knight is
such a brave piece where does it go it
goes in Knight to d7 the seemingly
impossible square because free pieces
are potentially defending that square
but in actual fact none of those pieces
can actually take the knight an
unbelievable idea and the pressure
against f6 is mounting so black isn't a
lot of trouble if he tries taking the
knight again we can take here with
checkmate ideas and if he takes with
either the knight or the bishop he will
lose his queen neppo has created an
attack out of nowhere and he went on to
win in beautiful style here very
impressive vision in this game well I
can't show you five best moves without
giving up a queen or two can i and this
nexus our pool is a very crisp example
very smooth very elegant it's white to
play and this is what I hope that most
of you can solve remember look out for
the most forcing moves which are checks
and captures kind of giving it away
there can you find how the nepo created
checkmate Queen to g7 check and this is
a very nice idea
obviously the Queen has to be captured
and now we take with the H pawn
forcing King to g8 and look how strong
this little guy becomes Knight to h6
an extremely elegant checkmate there so
a very crisp finished I hope a number of
you found that yourselves neppo has a
real force behind of a lot of his moves
and he is an expert at taking his
opponent's king apart and that's exactly
what he does here now in this position
it's clear that White has some fantastic
pieces aiming at the black King but the
bishop here rook on an open file Queen
potentially coming in but what move now
started a very strong attack and again I
suggest you pause and see how far you
can calculate here and the move is
Bishop takes h6 ripping open the black
King there and again the pawns around
opponents king and often act as
bodyguards and if you can assassinate
those bodyguards you will find a way
through to your opponent's king and
often be able to pull off and a
successful attack and the idea of this
is if pawn takes h6 the Queen now comes
in with check and after a king move like
King h8 the knight can come to f5 and
let's say rook to g8 I'm gonna give you
one more question here what would now be
a very beautiful winning move and if we
think logically we're trying to get to
the g7 square the rook is the only piece
defending that so we can use what we
call a destroy
action technique pause if you need to
rook to e8 sure and this is a very
beautiful way to force a checkmate ball
Queen coming in to one of these two
squares and if we go back to let's say G
takes f6
and King to h8 Knight to f5 if black
simply takes this one White has a
numerous threats here we have Queen f6
coming in with maybe a rook swing
bringing more pieces into the attack and
another idea let's save Knight d7
stopping that is the simple move Bishop
d3 and this has hints of Bobby Fischer
vs. Benko if you remember that very
famous idea where Bobby had a similar
idea of checkmating on HSN so very nice
idea and the game actually continued
Bishop age 2 but we saw a very similar
thing after Bishop f4 neppo continues
playing aggressively and this is a very
good tip bit here if you are attacking
always try to play the most aggressive
moves and Bishop takes g7 is similar to
the lines we just looked at after Queen
g4 Knight to f5 neppo gained a very
strong attack that led to victory very
nice play from this tactical genius
neppo at his greatest in an actual fact
out of all the players if I had to bet
on someone I would bet on nepo you heard
it here first I know he's not favorite
to go through but I think he's an
incredibly talented attacking player he
obviously has a team of good workers
behind him and the tournament is in
Russia what do you think do you think
neppo can face Magnus for the World
Championships do like and subscribe to
this video and I'll be back soon
covering the other players in the
candidates